Robert Habeck ist Vizekanzler
Wirtschaftsminister klimaminister er war
in den vergangenen Monaten auch das
Gesicht der Energie sorgen dieses Landes
jetzt würde ich mal sagen deutlich
sorgen freier Herr habe guten Abend
guten Abend Grüße wenn die Gaspreise
jetzt wieder auf dem Vorkriegsstand sind
wann erwarten sie denn dass das bei uns
allen auch tatsächlich im Portemonnaie
ankommt die Gaspreise die wir alle
bezahlen müssen setzen sich immer über
einen längeren einkaufszeitraum zusammen
das heißt noch sind die Preise die bei
uns ankommen durch die Preise des
letzten Jahres sehr hoch das kann sich
dann aber wirklich es kann sich dann
aber über das nächste Jahr wieder
abschleifen das hängt natürlich jetzt
von verschiedenen Voraussetzungen ab und
vielleicht bin ich damit bei dem Punkt
wir haben die Krise beherrschbar gemacht
das ist eine große gemeinschaftliche
Leistung dieses Landes aber die Krise
ist noch nicht vorbei wir sind nur weit
besser davor als wir es befürchten
mussten Ende des Sommers aber wir sind
noch lange noch nicht durch bleibt noch
eine Sekunde bei Kreisen ist denn dann
noch Raum für multimilliardenschwere
Gas- und Strompreis Bremsen des Staates
mit unseren Steuergeldern nun die werden
wenn die Preise so bleiben sowohl bei
der Abschöpfung also Gewinne die wir
abziehen wie auch bei dem was wir
ausgleichen müssen geringer ausfallen
aber es ist ja wie sie eben gerade
gesagt haben dennoch so dass die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher die
Preise die im letzten Jahr aufgelaufen
sind zum Teil mit bezahlen müssen also
neu Verträge können im Moment um oder
unter der definierten Höhe der
gaspreisbremse geschlossen werden aber
diejenigen die in Verträgen stehen haben
die Preiserhöhungen noch zu tragen
deswegen haben die Bremsen sehr wohl
noch ihre Richtigkeit und ihre Bedeutung
nur wird vielleicht das Volumen etwas
geringer ausfallen und das wäre ja gut
wenn zu werden das wäre gut wenn es so
wäre Entspannung hört man plötzlich
wieder als Adjektiv als Substantiv bei
dem Thema Entspannung die ganze
Situation man könnte vielleicht ein
bisschen salopp auch sagen das große
Problem ist nicht mehr dass es zu kalt
ist bei uns sondern dass es zu heiß wird
und damit sind wir bei möglichen neuen
Spielraum für die Politik und damit auch
beim Thema nutzerrat das ja aktuell die
Grünen zerreißt kann man sagen die Zeit
für Kompromisse ist vorbei hat gestern
hier bei uns im heute schon mal ein
Klimaforscher gesagt heißt das denn für
sie man könnte ja auch jetzt angesichts
der neuen Situation nutzerer doch noch
mal neu verhandeln ich will dem Kollegen
nicht zu nahe treten aber wir haben
gerade über die Krise gesprochen die wir
eingedämmt haben aber die noch nicht
vorbei ist wir haben diese Krise
beherrschbar gemacht weil viele Menschen
und die Unternehmen Gas eingespart haben
und wir den Gasverbrauch aus dem
Stromsektor rausgedrängt haben mit und
das ist nicht so auf wie stolz bin mit
zusätzlicher braun Kohle Verstromung
davon
Kompromisslosigkeit zu reden verkennt
die Wirklichkeit sind ja noch immer zwei
Krisen da und wir haben im letzten Jahr
tatsächlich eine gefährlich eine
brandgefährliche realistische Gefahr
gehabt dass Deutschland kalt bleibt im
Winter und deswegen sind viele Studien
die vor dem Ukraine Krieg erstellt
wurden als wir noch nicht zusätzliche
Mengen braunkohlestrom an die an den
Markt bringen mussten nicht auf das Jahr
23 und fortfolgende zu beziehen die sind
einfach falsch und wir sind im Moment in
einem Modus wo wir zwei Krisen
kompromisshaft zusammenbringen können
aber das heißt da habe ich diese großen
Anstrengungen da jetzt Energie zu
besorgen auch wenn die unter
klimagesichtspunkten schädlich ist diese
Anstrengungen müssen weitergehen
sie müssen dann hinten raus eingefangen
werden und deswegen ist das was gerade
mit dem Begriff oder mit dem Ortsnamen
lützerat diskutiert wird aus meiner
Sicht nicht richtig
lützerath ist nicht das weiter so der
Energiepolitik der Vergangenheit für
Strom von Braunkohle es ist nicht wie
behauptet wird dass ewige weiter so es
ist der Schlussstrich der unter wir
mussten leider in diesem Jahr
zusätzliche Mengen Braunkohle die
eigentlich abgeschaltet werden sollten
in den Markt reinlassen um die
gasmangelage zu verhindern aber hinten
raus haben wir den die Verstromung von
Braun Kohle von 38 auf 30 vorgezogen
leider konnten wir das Dorf lützerat das
ja schon abgebaggert werden sollte dass
RWE gehört dass leer gezogen ist das in
Wahrheit gar kein Dorf mehr ist sondern
leere Hüfte nicht mehr retten aber es
ist das Ende der braunen Kohle
verstromungen NRW es ist nicht das
weiter so und insofern mit großem
Respekt vor der Bewegung aus meiner
Ansicht nach der Ort das falsche Symbol
aber Herr Habeck lützerath ist eben ein
Symbol sie haben es ja gerade selbst
gesagt dass weit über dieses Dorf dieses
winzig kleine Dorf hinausgeht und die
Grünen verlieren da gerade enorm an
Vertrauen und dann Glaubwürdigkeit bei
klassisch grünen WLAN da protestiert ja
im Grunde genommen ihre eigene Wähler
Klientel gegen ihre Politik ja das ist
so das tut auch weh und das ist auch
nicht gut oder
nichts was mich
also es fasst mich auch an oder treibt
mich um so wie alle in meiner Partei
aber trotzdem müssen wir das erklären
was richtig ist und richtig wahr leider
die gasmangelage eine Energie Notlage in
Deutschland abzuwehren auch durch
zusätzliche verstorbenung von Braunkohle
und hinten raus den Kohleausstieg
vorzuziehen und die Argumentation die
ich jetzt aus Teilen der Klimabewegung
höre definierte Enddaten Kohle 2030
brauchen wir gar nicht der Markt regelt
das alles die Stromverbräuche gehen von
alleine zurück oder die Zertifikate der
Zertifikate Handel sorgt dafür dass es
unattraktiv wird ist eine erstaunliche
Argumentation denn sie würde ja eins zu
eins übersetzt bedeuten dass wir gar
nicht mehr über Daten von Kohleausstieg
reden müssen insofern nein ich finde den
Protest wie er aufgesetzt wird nicht
richtig an dieser Stelle wir setzen den
Kohleausstieg 8 Jahre früher im Westen
um und ich nehme an die Bewegung die
jetzt in unserer diskutiert wird von mir
erwarten dass ich ähnliches auch im
Osten Versuche und nicht sage na ja
Daten brauchen wir nicht das regelt
einfach der Markt Robert habe vielen
Dank für das Gespräch danke Ihnen